après cinq mois de travaux ce scanner
dernière génération vient compléter le
plateau technique du centre médical des
pyramides
parmi ces avantages un confort pour le
patient et un diagnostic plus précis
pour les professionnels on a la chance
d'avoir des coupes on appelle ça des
coupes extrêmement fils parce que un
scanner ce à faire des coupes on va
découper le coran en fines tranches
donc là on va arriver sur des coupes de
jusqu'à 0 3 mm donc on a des indications
très précises très fort et un scanner
très rapide donc un poumon par exemple
ça va se faire entre 2 et 3 secondes
utilisé lors deux pathologies
pulmonaires de cancers ou pour des
douleurs abdominales l'équipement va
permettre d'accueillir une trentaine de
patients par jour
cela faisait plusieurs années qu'il n'y
avait pas eu de nouveaux scanners dans
la région il faut que les médecins si
généralistes aient accès à cette
révolution technologique leur permet de
gagner du temps de la précision bien sûr
coût de l'installation de ce nouvel
équipement médical 1 millions d'euros
il a uniquement été financée par des
radiologues de la région la ville a été
un soutien logistique
nous les avons accompagnés en essayant
de faire au mieux pour que
l'installation se fasse au plus vite
notamment sur les installations
électriques
c'est un plus sur le territoire est
d'ailleurs le plan local d'urbanisme de
maurepas le nouveau plan local
d'urbanisme qui a été voté par
l'ensemble des élus du conseil municipal
en septembre dernier permettent
aujourd'hui au centre médical même de se
développer
l'équipe du centre médical espère
bientôt installer une irm pour ainsi
compléter le plateau technique du centre
médical mort d'asia